*Music plays*
(Marzia):Look at the snail... he's so cute
it is so cute.. oh my god
(Marzia): Oh and when you move in here all of the butterflies come out
(Pewds): uhm..  (Marzia): it's so cute
No no no Marzia hates butterflies, what
(Marzia): I hate butterfly!!
(Marzia): This mother duck and her ducklings...they are so cute
(Marzia): Bro, come and see (Pewds): I'm sorry, I'm sorry
Yeah, those are adorable
Oh my god, that's so cute
(Marzia): How do I get the... (Pewds): Hey watch out!
(Pewds): He peed on you! (Marzia): What is happening?
OOOOHHHH
(Marzia): Kill him!
(Marzia): Oh
I'll poop here
(Marzia): How do you lure him?
I don't know, we have to figure that out you fucking idiot
*fart sound*
(Marzia): OH MY GOD! Did you just say that for real on camera?
(Pewds): Yes (Marzia): Is there a frog? Do I like frogs?
Yeah you do
(Marzia): Oh my god this frog is so cute!
Okay let's catch some butterflies
You hate butterflies right?
(Marzia): I hate them so let's catch them...(Pewds): I know don't worry (Marzia):...and then we'll eradicate them from the planet
Got one!
You caught a ladybug!
(Marzia): Do I like ladybugs?
Yeah...no
(Marzia): No?
No
(Marzia): EWW!
Okay good
Finally you are doing something useful
(Marzia) :You are not funny...this is  (Pewds): I'm sorry this was a joke for the thing okay?
(Marzia): You're nasty (Pewds): I'm sorry, I'm... (Marzia): You're a bad boyfriend
I am bad boyfriend...I'm sorry
You're a shitty girlfriend
(Marzia): You will never see these nips again
No, I don't...stop showing your nips please
Okay?
Thank you
What are you doin?
What are you doin right now?
(Marzia): Do you love me?
I of...
What are you doing?
(Marzia): I can show you my butt
*Pewds laughs*
(Marzia): Dance, wiggle wiggle, dance wiggle wiggle (Pewds): DAMN!! (Marzia): Dance, wiggle wiggle
Oh my god you did so well Marzia
(Marzia): Thanks I really tried hard
Aww
Uh, um, thank you so much for playing with me today
(Marzia): I play with you every day
Uh huh
(Marzia): And I play with you every night
How about for the thumbnail, we do a little kiss?
*kissing that sounds too wet and aggressive*
(Felix coming up for air) da fuck?
*choking sound*
*Felix laughs*
Okay...yeah
(Marzia): Yeah
*vomit sounds*
*montage music*